[Música]
tras la quiebra del silicon y el
signature Bank el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden aseguró que el sistema
financiero del país es seguro y añadió
que su gobierno ha tomado medidas para
asegurar el dinero de sus clientes estas
considerada la peor crisis bancaria del
país desde 2008
el gobierno de Australia confirmó la
compra de tres submarinos de propulsión
nuclear fabricados por Estados Unidos
con opción de Añadir dos más en el
futuro la compra tiene lugar en el marco
de la alianza aucus junto a Washington y
Londres para hacer contrapeso a China
el gobierno colombiano y una parte de
las disidencias de la antigua guerrilla
de las FARC establecerán una mesa de
diálogo así lo anunció el presidente
Gustavo Petro luego de que la fiscalía
levantara las órdenes de captura contra
19 integrantes de ese grupo
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos donde continúa el temor
financiero tras la quiebra de los bancos
silicon Valley Bank y signature Bank el
presidente Joe vendió un parte de
tranquilidad indicando que el sistema
financiero del país es seguro y
reiterando que su gobierno está tomando
medidas para proteger el dinero de los
clientes las autoridades federales
intervinieron los depósitos de esas
entidades el fin de semana al tiempo que
El Ejecutivo señaló que la medida no
tendrá un costo para los contribuyentes
Max Pérez Gallardo nos Explica qué ha
hecho Estados Unidos para evitar que se
repita una crisis como la que vivió el
sistema financiero en 2008
la quiebra de silicon Valley Bank y Take
nature Bank representa la mayor prueba
para el sistema financiero
estadounidense desde la crisis de 2008 e
incluso mientras el presidente Joe biden
intentaba restaurar la confianza en el
sector bancario estadounidense admitió
que era necesaria una regulación más
estricta voy a pedir al congreso y a los
reguladores bancarios que refuercen las
normas de los bancos para que sea menos
probable que este tipo de quiebra
bancaria se repita y para proteger el
empleo y las pequeñas empresas
estadounidenses para evitar que se
repitiera la crisis financiera mundial
Washington promulgó la ley dot Frank en
2010 la normativa implementó normas
sobre cómo pueden invertir los bancos
así como los requisitos mínimos para los
activos líquidos también estableció
organismos reguladores para vigilar el
sector de los servicios financieros sin
embargo en 2018 bajo el mandato del
entonces presidente Donald Trump se
debilitaron algunas cláusulas de la
Dodge bancos como es estaban a favor de
este retroceso argumentando que no eran
lo suficientemente Grandes como para
justificar la supervisión la medida les
permitió invertir más de sus depósitos y
ganar más dinero para ejecutivos y
accionistas los detractores de la
desregulación entienden que tuvieron la
razón como la senadora demócrata
Elizabeth Warren que mencionó las
quiebras bancarias son el resultado
directo del debilitamiento de las normas
financieras por parte de los líderes de
Washington la secretaría del tesoro de
Estados Unidos Janeth jelen ya se ha
mostrado partidaria de reforzar las
competencias de los organismos
reguladores sin embargo biden se
enfrenta a un congreso dividido lo que
podría dificultar la aprobación de leyes
de regulación más estrictas continuamos
en California donde el presidente se
reunió con los primeros ministros de
Australia y Reino Unido Antonio alvanici
y Richi sunak los tres son signatarios
del acuerdo aucus desde la base naval de
San Diego by den defendió el pacto como
parte de un indopacífico libre y abierto
previamente el asesor de seguridad
Nacional de la Casa Blanca Jake sol y
van anunció que Australia comprará tres
submarinos con propulsión nuclear a
Estados Unidos con posibilidad de
adquirir otros dos más adelante
[Música]
una de las naves que ven detrás de mí es
un submarino clase Virginia de
propulsión nuclear un usac miserer estos
submarinos de primera clase son La
Vanguardia del poder naval
estadounidense
tienen tecnología de propulsión de alta
gama que les da una maniobrabilidad
inigualable y con el apoyo del Congreso
a principios de los 2030 Estados Unidos
venderá tres de estos submarinos
Australia con la opción de vender otros
dos si es necesario iniciando así su
capacidad una década antes de lo que
muchos predijeron
dos personas perdieron la vida y otras
nueve resultaron heridas tras ser
atropelladas en la ciudad canadiense de
anki en la provincia de Quebec las
autoridades señalaron que las
circunstancias de los hechos aún están
siendo investigadas y el conductor del
vehículo que en principio huyó luego se
entregó a las autoridades y has
mantenido bajo custodia el Primer
Ministro canadiense ellos te introdudó
envió sus condolencias a las víctimas
vamos a Colombia donde el presidente
Gustavo Petro anunció que dará inicio a
una mesa de diálogo con el Estado Mayor
central uno de los grupos disidentes de
la antigua guerrilla de las farcas que
se abstuvo de firmar el acuerdo de paz
de 2016 como primera medida la fiscalía
suspendió las órdenes de captura de 19
de los integrantes de este grupo de
disidentes que ahora será parte de los
negociadores
Colombia comenzará un segundo proceso de
paz el presidente Gustavo Petro anunció
este lunes una mesa de diálogo con el
Estado Mayor central una de las
disidencias de las antiguas FARC que es
liderada por alias Iván mordisco con
esta posibilidad que inicia en el día de
hoy
da la actitud del fiscal de aceptar los
nombres de las personas que actuaran
como voceros de esa agrupación
Prácticamente la mitad de las personas
armadas hoy
entran a un proceso de paz con el
gobierno para que este proceso pueda
llevarse a cabo la fiscalía general de
Colombia suspendió 19 órdenes de captura
por pedido del gobierno para él esas esa
organización es una organización que
tiene isla dota de un carácter político
para negociar acuerdos de paz con el
gobierno nacional en Franz 24 Jorge
mantilla investigador en asuntos de
conflicto y crimen organizado explicó
las posibles dificultades que surgir en
las conversaciones entre el gobierno y
el Estado Mayor central el Gobierno ya
ha reconocido explícitamente al Estado
Mayor central como un grupo de carácter
político los retos tienen que ver
justamente que esta Estructura No es un
grupo propiamente unificado hay más de
25 frentes dentro de lo que se denomina
Estado Mayor central gran parte de las
dudas tienen que ver con si hay unidad
de mando si efectivamente son un
interlocutor que tenga unos criterios
claros para negociar Además del Estado
Mayor central el estado colombiano
apunta a tener acercamientos en las
próximas semanas con la segunda
marquetalia otra de las disidencias de
las FARC el precandidato presidencial
venezolano Enrique capriles aseguró que
el presidente Nicolás Maduro apostará
por la abstención y la división de la
oposición en las elecciones de 2024 El
reconocido disidente llamó a los líderes
opositores a unirse para poner fin al
chavismo según capriles maduro no cuenta
con apoyo popular tras la crisis que
vive el país que no ha permitido crear
empleos y que mantiene una elevada
inflación
a eso nos estamos enfrentando los
venezolanos pero aquí hay una decisión
que tomar o enfrentamos y luchamos
o no lo hacemos yo decido hacerlo
porque estoy convencido sigo estando
convencido que la fuerza de este país
puede imponerse democráticamente Sigo
creyendo que es el gran reto Eso no
significa ser ingenuo Esas son las
convicciones eso no es lo que somos
Además nosotros somos demócratas el
ciclón ha golpeado fuertemente a Perú
dejando al menos 58 muertos y su
influencia también se siente en Ecuador
donde se han registrado fuertes
precipitaciones e inundaciones dejando
al menos cinco víctimas Gustavo Ortega
corresponsal en Quito nos informó Cuál
es la situación de los damnificados y
que ayudas anunciado el gobierno se
comenta que en principio se hablaba de
563 personas damnificadas Pero ya el
número de personas ha Doblado inclusive
esta cifra que ha hecho El Ejecutivo
nacional bueno ha hablado de entrega de
bonos de desastres ha dicho que
ofrecerá principalmente ayudas
económicas y créditos también para la
reactivación económica se registra hasta
el momento por lo menos pérdidas
el sector agropecuario mil productores
agropecuarios han perdidos sus cosechas
también se ha hablado sobre la
construcción de hospitales
en el específicamente en la ciudad de
chone Se ha perdido el hospital
principal de esta ciudad que tenía 40
años de construcción y tiene pérdidas y
recuperables El Ejecutivo nacional ha
hablado de la construcción de un nuevo
hospital y en la ciudad de Guayaquil hay
zonas donde se han colapsado por el agua
no se mantiene Se ha perdido el servicio
el servicio de agua potable y
básicamente se habla también de 54 casos
de electospirosis la principal
preocupación sanitaria que en este
momento mantiene el país a causa de
estas intensas lluvias
es todo por el momento en France 24
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]